Malcolm he's obviously a huge part of
your life he's almost 16
do you work do you is it terrifying and
you worried about that him turning 16 I
am a bit worried about it just because
like it's such a weird age of all this
angst and stuff he is so sassy he is a
good kid but he is sassy boy yeah I know
like I was able to come to things I've
become like I have a good median an
actor and because I had to overcome a
lot of struggle my dad wasn't there when
I was around you know and got a really
rough childhood yeah I'm a single parent
and a lot of struggle and financial
hardship and I'm just looking at my son
I'm like there's just no way he's gonna
grow up to be a great human being I've
been I've been too good of a father you
mean there's no struggle there's no
struggle for Mouse anything he was it
just appears it's just but I kind of
like it I want that I want I want him to
be the first member of this family that
just coasts and just not working oh I
asked him what he wanted to do for a
living he goes like what do you mean
take out the trash yeah god bless him I
you talked about this I know this story
but I do tell a story about your son you
have a nickname for him which is mr. hot
nuts
I do yeah and the story of how that
nickname came about is is one of my
favorite one of my favorite things that
you talk about Seattle Washington just
traveling with my son cuz there's a
summer and I try to keep him with me
during that time and he was being pretty
sassy and he wanted to eat every time we
go to a hotel but because of his autism
and his disability we try to keep a very
structured so we check into a hotel and
I heard him a cheese pizza with extra
sauce he eats it all by himself like
it's home alone too it's a great time
right right but this time he didn't want
it he didn't want to wear pants he
didn't wanna wear underwear he was just
leaning back just leaning back my foot
some pants on he's like no and I just
like I'm just gonna watch what happens
so he's just leaning back with all this
confidence that reminds me that he is
half white half the cheese the sauce
starts to slide off and it lands
directly don't get ahead of me that's
directly on his nuts I loved it she's
been kind of asking for sassy I'm gonna
put your pants on he's just yeah yeah
and then he's just laying back he's good
on sauce on just running around the
hotel room going hot daddy that's how he
got that nickname so he has had struggle
thank you tonight